on va continuer bien entendu parler
d'eux on va continuer de parler de cette
information de cette attaque au couteau
qui a eu lieu en début de matinée dans
le 11e arrondissement de paris nous
sommes toujours avec notre éditorialiste
alexis pour alexis merci d'être encore
une fois avec nous sur rt france thomas
bonnet le le disait le gouvernement suit
de près forcément cette affaire on
attend d'un moment à l'autre
une annonce peut-être de jean castex le
premier ministre ou de gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur qu'est ce que
vous attendez de cette première réponse
politique il ya un savoir quelles sont
les motivations du suspect qui a été
arrêté qu'elles sont aussi les réalités
des réseaux s'il y en a derrière cette
attaque et s'il ya de risques plus
grands sur le territoire d'autres
attaques à suivre à savoir est ce que on
a affaire à un acte isolé ou bien
quelque chose de beaucoup plus organisés
comme ça avait été le cas pour les
attentats de 2015 et puis savoir quelles
vont être les dispositifs de
renforcement de sécurité dans les jours
à venir si jamais il était avéré que ce
n'était pas un loup solitaire mais bien
un élément d'un ba réseaux djihadistes
plus large qui avait agit aujourd'hui
sur commande on en parlait avec notre
invité avant vous cette réponse
politique qui va arriver plus de deux
heures et demie après les après les
faits est ce que ça vous étonne
ou alors est ce que le gouvernement a
raison de prendre ses précautions
non le gouvernement a raison de prendre
ses précautions on doit connaître les
motivations de la séance à voir celle
des revendications mais il faut savoir
que les jours derniers al qaïda a
clairement ciblées la france compte tenu
de la publication à nouveau par charlie
hebdo des dessins du prophète et du
procès de charlie hebdo bien entendu
donc la france est une cible
il ya eu une alerte à la bombe à la tour
eiffel
mercredi on est en droit de demander aux
politiques une information transparente
sur le degré d' alerte des services à
savoir est ce que ces menaces sont
sérieuses est ce qu'aujourd'hui ça fait
partie d'une attaque djihadistes ou non
et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que quelles
vont être les les moyens mis à
disposition du ministère de l'intérieur
et du renseignement pour protéger les
français alexis un poulain cette attaque
au couteau bien sûr rappelle la tacc 1
contre charlie hebdo en janvier 2015 on
évoquait tout à l'heure un contexte un
peu particulier justement cette attaque
qui a lieu dans la rue des anciens
locaux de charlie hebdo la drh menacé il
y a quelques jours obligé de quitter son
domicile ancien drh de charlie hebdo et
puis le procès actuellement en cours
tout cela fait beaucoup
ce sont forcément des liens qu'on ne
peut pas délier oui évidemment le climat
aujourd'hui revient remet toute la
lumière sur le risque dit à dist en
france sur l'horreur qui a été 2015 à
charlie hebdo sur la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'informer et
sur la sécurité
plus globalement parce que la menace
terroriste
malheureusement est toujours présente
les réseaux terroristes d'ailleurs
trouve un nouveau regain au mali ou
ailleurs on voit bien que cette menace
là n'a pas été éradiqué loin de là et
qu'ils continuent d'agir dans l'ombre et
continuent de prendre la france pour
cible d'attaqués et ça ça n'a pas changé
malheureusement depuis 2015
donc là encore la question se pose de la
question de l'intensité de la question
du retour de deux d'attaquants sur notre
territoire
aussi deux personnes qui étaient jusqu'à
présent en prison qui vont sans doute
sortir puisqu'ils ont purgé leur peine
et comme on vous le savez le débat sur
la déradicalisation a toujours lieu à
savoir est ce que ça fonctionne ou pas
que ton des radicaliser un assaillant
djihadistes ou
un proche cette mouvance tout ça reste
d'actualité
et malheureusement la tacc d'aujourd'hui
dont on ne sait toujours pas si elle est
motivée par des motifs djihadistes ou
bien nous rappelle parce qu'elle a lieu
à côté de charlie hebdo les heures
sombres de 2015 cette attaque au couteau
un qui a eu lieu dans un autre contexte
particulier celui de la crise sanitaire
est ce que c'est moi qu'on vient de
traverser à vivre avec le co vide 19 qui
nous a pas fait oublier un petit peu à
tous la menace terroriste qui planait au
dessus de nos têtes
oui c'est s'était depuis quelques temps
la menace c'était le virus s'était pas
le terrorisme mais là ne chassait pas
l'autre en réalité l'un se superposer à
l'autre donc on redécouvre bien le
niveau d' alerte vigipirate n'avait pas
baisser son niveau d alerte mais sas
ajoute bien sûr à l'incertitude à la
peur des populations puisque le virus
n'a pas aidé à retrouver de la sérénité
au sein des populations de nos pays donc
on est dans un cadre mondial de grande
incertitude de avec ce virus qui n'en
finit pas on n'a toujours pas de
traitement est sage et s'ajoute enfin on
revient sur le devant de la scène
la menace extérieure du terrorisme
selanne n'a jamais non plus disparus
même si on a pu croire un moment qu'elle
était de moindre intensité puisque les
djihadistes d'al j'avais perdu beaucoup
de terrain
mais on voit bien qu'il ya une
recrudescence maintenant en afrique
subsaharienne et ailleurs de ces groupes
qui retrouve à nouveau les moyens de
s'organiser et c'est ça qui peut
inquiéter aujourd'hui les services
vous parliez à l'instant du de
l'intensité du retour des attaques
terroristes sur le sol français
on sait que le parquet anti terroriste a
été saisie est ce que c'est justement
une des questions la question de
l'intensité à laquelle va devoir
répondre le parquet antiterroriste oui
absolument à savoir si comme je le
disais il s'agit d'une personne isolée
ou si des réseaux sont à la manoeuvre et
qu'il faut s'attendre dans les jours les
semaines qui viennent à d'autres
attaques de plus grande ampleur ça c'est
au service de faire leur travail au parc
et bien sûr antiterroriste de voir
qu'ils sont qui sont les personnes
arrêtées aujourd'hui qu'elle quelles
sont les motivations derrière et quels
sont aujourd'hui les la probabilité du
risque de l'autre deux attaques sur
notre territoire
donc c'est bien que le parquet soit
saisie immédiatement
on voit bien aussi que là les politiques
ont pris immédiatement les le bon
réflexe de se rendre dans les mondes
dans les stalles de coordination à bord
ou ailleurs et de pouvoir travailler
ensemble pour que tous les services et
le même degré d'information et qu'on
puisse mettre en place le degré maximum
d' alerte pour prévenir tout attentat
qui pourrait avoir lieu à la suite de
celui ci alexis poulain des attaques ou
en tout cas des modes opératoires
différents des attaques terroristes là
que l'on a pu connaître notamment en
janvier en novembre 2015 cette fois une
attaque à l'armé blanche
on imagine un contexte plus compliqué en
mode opératoire plus compliqué en tout
cas à prévoir pour les forces de police
oui s'il cesse vide d'attac au couteau
où des attaques à la voiture-bélier
comme ça a été le cas les deux ces
dernières fois beaucoup plus difficile
de prévenir l'origine le dieu de la tacc
que quand il s'agit de se fournir avec
des armes lourdes ou bien de préparer
des bombes mais l'un ne veut pas dire
que l'autre a disparu non plus peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui des groupes sont en train
de préparer des attaques de plus grande
ampleur le fait est que ces attaques à
l'armé blanche peuvent se multiplier
partout sur le territoire et sans que la
réponse policière puisse être immédiate
et c'est là tout le problème en fait du
renseignement bien de savoir quelles
sont les cibles aujourd'hui sous les
radars qui sont à surveiller de plus
près si jamais elle devait venir à
passer à l'acte donc malheureusement
c'est nous ce nouveau mode opératoire
qui a été prouvée puisque c'étaient les
états major d'al qaïda qui demandait à
leurs attaquants d'agir de la sorte ces
nouveaux modes opératoires rendent
encore plus difficiles de travail du
renseignement merci beaucoup alexis
poule en avoir répondu une nouvelle fois
à nos questions à sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialiste à
rester bien avec nous reviendra bien sûr
viens vers vous tout au long de cette
journée